right good morning everybody and welcome
to this joint audit and standards
committee I'm councilor John Matheson
and I'm chairing the meeting today
may I first of all remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
please ensure microphones are turned off
when not in use
but you do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak persistently interrupt you may be
asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off and there's a 10
pound fine for anybody that breaches
that goes to the chairs Charities it's
not been reminded any of that recently
but it will be a thing in this committee
okay
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the
modern.gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and we'll be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
attendance this morning we have officers
Arthur charvonia chief executive and for
these purposes as a returning officer
we have Melissa Evans director of
corporate resources
Jan Robinson Deputy launching officer
Bob Palmer corporate manager Finance
commissioning and procurement
we have
um committee officer Bethany Webb and
acquire a team trying to get over the
difficulties of this morning
and we also have a guest we welcome
David Green from Arlene close
moving to the agenda
apologies for absence and substitutions
we have apologies from Council on Davies
and councilor in Huron and we have the
Council of John Wyman substituting
thank you
right do we have any Declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interests by
members
all right good
right moving on to confirming the
minutes of the meeting held on the 31st
of July
anybody got any points on accuracy
some would like to propose and second
that thank you thank you
right on to the vote
thank you chair that is now in progress
on modgov
thank you chair that is eight rates four
and one of sanctions that is carried
right the minutes have been confirmed
next to receive notification of any
petitions in accordance with the
council's petitioning scheme none
receives chair thank you
have we any questions by the public none
received
do we have any questions from counselors
man received chair all right
right we move on to the first main item
on the agenda
which is to invite the chief executive
to introduce the report to the committee
on the
elections review draft action plan
thank you chairman and thank you
councilors so as counselors will be
aware this is very much part two of this
report in the sense that I brought a
report to both full councils earlier in
the year and as per the recommendations
that came to full Council one of those
was that the draft action plan come to
jasc for you to review that draft action
plan so as I say this is very much part
two you'll be pleased to know I don't
intend to take you through line by line
the three pages of the action plan
starting on page 47 but it would just
say a couple of things I suppose in
terms of other progress over and above
what's in the action plan and then I
suspect my colleagues to my left may
want to say a couple of things and they
were happy to take questions so just in
terms of broader progress so ahead of
this meeting we met last week with the
Electoral commission who as you can
imagine we've stayed in regular contact
with throughout always since May and who
we would have regular contact with
anyway through the course of normal
occurrences they we took them through
this specific action plan
and they are broadly speaking happy with
the progress that we've made that what
we've also invited them to do and I'm
pleased to say that they've accepted is
that they join our project board
meetings so we have currently monthly
project board meetings those will
increase in frequency as we head towards
uh next scheduled or any unscheduled
elections and so they're happy to take
part and be part of that project board
which I hope will give additional
resilience and governance to our process
which is a good thing the other change
is Jan Robinson you're obviously
familiar with Jan has been providing
support both herself and her teams are
lending her team on an ad hoc basis to
help the elections team since May and
that's continuing at this point in time
but the lady who you're not familiar
with to her left is Jillian fryer
Jillian has joined us initially as the
interim corporate manager for elections
I say initially because we're out to
recruitment for a direct replacement to
that role a permanent replacement to
that role that advert closes at the end
of this week and we're interviewing next
week I believe it is so I'm hopeful that
we will have a permanent person in post
as the elections manager as soon as
possible but in any event we've
commissioned Jillian to stay with us
through until May next year uh come what
may on the basis that we need as we know
as is reflected in the two reports that
were received we need to add capacity
into the elections team as a whole so
Jillian would be providing that
additional capacity currently as I say
as the manager and then becoming an
election specialist within the team
running through till May and depending
upon when the general election is we may
extend that slightly further and if you
know please do tell me because that
would be very helpful to know when there
is sooner rather than later but I
suspect we're all in the dark as to when
the general election will actually be so
that was all I was going to say in terms
of the action plan itself and immediate
progress since um in terms of the
division of roles so Jan is providing
the day-to-day line management for the
elections team so paying rations annual
leave and those kind of things and as I
say lending some of her team into the
into the elections team on an ad hoc
basis and then Jillian is providing the
project management and elections
management within the team which jointly
have helped reduce the action plan that
you've got in front of you
if I stop there chair and look to my
colleagues if there's anything they want
to add if not happy to take questions as
counselors may have
thank you questions then
great thank you very much I've combed
through the external and internal
reviews and a a common feature is the
need for adequate And Timely forward
planning
um
which is why you've produced the action
plan I guess I'm slightly concerned that
there's an awful lot of Amber and red on
it at the moment I don't know when that
was actually
um after audited
I mean how up-to-date is the action plan
itself
uh so it's as far as possible up to date
it's not old in that sense so I think
for the purposes of today assume it's as
of today
um you're right some things will have
moved ever so slightly since I'm less
concerned I would say about the amount
of Amber and red and the reason I say
that is because some of those actions
are very specifically relates to
district and Parish elections and so
what I'm particularly focused on is that
we learn the lessons now while still
fresh in people's minds but in terms of
implementing those things we don't need
to in fact there are other things that
are a higher priority that we need to
implement now in terms of the frequency
or sorry in terms of delivery of the
action plan so what you will probably
see although I haven't gone through and
checked it from an audit perspective
exactly with that question in mind but I
think what you'll probably see is
particularly the red actions they don't
relate to sorry they relate to elections
that we don't have to run again and
won't have to run again for another four
years or three and a half years and so
that's why they appear in that way right
now what we have to prioritize is the
delivery of annual canvas which is
ongoing the delivery of the changes that
government has made around elections
more generally so for example from the
end of October in
postal voter you'll have to apply online
and you won't be able to do it in the
way that other previously and that's
a subtle as just
Excel we're prioritizing that and
preparation for the police and crime
commissioner elections that we know
we've got next May and equally for the
Parliamentary that we know we're going
to have at least uh
January 2025 more likely at some point
during the calendar year but you're
right and we won't take our eye off of
those other elements as well because
they need to progress at the right time
thank you so I I take your point
entirely my concern is with the general
election depends on which reporters you
read but it could be as early as
November this year
could be
so if it were called with 25 days notice
for November or early December are we
going to be ready
I think the honest answer is we're never
ready if an election is called at 25
days notice
um and equally the other honest answer
is we have no choice but to be ready in
terms of we have to deliver it so yes we
will be the reality is if it were cool
today the impact for the council's
resources would be significant because
effectively a whole lot of other things
would stop in order to make sure that we
could deliver the general election and
the other key piece and you're
absolutely right as you said earlier
that comes through loud and clear
through the external report the external
abroad and the internal report is the
need for project management
um ironically of course delivery of a
parliamentary election in many respects
is a lot easier than parish and town
council elections there are far fewer
moving Parts
um there are only limited number of
candidates it's a it is an easier
exercise in that sense but the scale is
bigger because the turnout is higher and
one of the things that we've been I
didn't mention it in my Preamble as it
were but one of the things we've been
identifying in the last couple of weeks
is a new count venue because we know
that our account venue at West depart
will be closed by Christmas and so we've
had to identify a new place to run the
elections from the last parliamentary we
actually delivered in this building we
don't think that was uh it was fine but
it's not ideal and so we've been looking
at that but I think Jill wanted to come
in
I was just going to say that um the
county election officers have a meeting
um next month and we and that's top of
the agenda so so we are all ready and um
organizing just sort of and we the
majority of the staff were on a training
on Thursday which was all about how to
cope with the snap general election and
cross boundaries because I mean you all
know that the constituency boundaries
have changed so that's one of the um
topics that we're talking about in in
October with the county election
officers as well so we started
if people haven't spotted it the new
constituency or sorry the revised
boundaries for South Norfolk
constituency become easier for us
because they become coterminers with
baber so
it's a bit away ballot papers to another
area for them to count or equally like
to take them in but the other areas that
we are likely to be involved in are much
more complicated because they involve
giving and taking from other areas and
we have
formal confirmation as to which
constituencies we are responsible for
administering I think it's a fair bet
and a fairly obvious one that we will be
doing South uh Suffolk as I say for
obvious reasons but we will we are
likely to have more constituencies
obviously that planning is therefore
it's a county-wide exercise as Jill says
yeah there aren't too many people
itching to itching to get in so one more
go so I'm really interested in this
um so Waverly Valley
which is is most of or most of it sits
in what was mid-suffolk but it's got a
bit of South Norfolk are we going to be
responsible for that so formally we
don't know
um in terms of the proportions so a
small Slither of waveny Valley sits in
East Suffolk
and then the balance is in South Norfolk
and in mid-suffolk actually the
electorate numbers are something like
400 more electors in South Norfolk
rather than in mid-suffolk we've been
consulted as returning officer by dluck
as to our preferences
and their instinct which is purely based
on numbers was that they were going to
give it to South Norfolk we have
proposed I say we I mean me but also I
mean South Norfolk and East Suffolk
we've proposed that that becomes a
constituency that mid-suffolk administs
but that's a bit we haven't had
confirmation of so we've said yes fine
there's 400 extra but actually it's so
close and it's uh in Suffolk
and therefore we felt it more
appropriately to be administered from
Suffolk not from Norfolk
thank you further questions councilor
Patchett
and councilor Marriott after that thank
you chair
um just a question about
um
the charges for Parish councils done did
did we offer any discount to any of the
parish councils for sort of perhaps a
less than perfect service and and also
did any of them sort of request a
discount for the for the overall
Services thank you so we certainly
haven't offered uh any sort of discounts
and I'll look to my colleagues to the
left as to whether any of them are
formally asked for a discount I'm not
aware that they have they haven't come
by me
there's lots of shaking of heads
um I was just wondering looking at all
these actions and there are lots of them
required but have they been prioritized
in any way for example I'm looking at
the creating a comprehensive
Communications plan should an election
be called early I would have thought
that hasn't started I'd have thought
that might be one of the priorities
um I have a meeting
um at the beginning of October with the
media team with Christine and Brad and
um that's what we're going to work on
can I just um come in as well just to
say that obviously Jill's this is week
three for Jill so
um you know when we wrote the report it
was sort of week one and a half so
um it is you know on work ongoing we're
doing we've done lots of work already
but more to come and there's going to be
a more detailed election project
board and it will detail the Milestones
the dates who it's assigned to but we
just need to work on that we've already
had a sort of morning where we've
identified all the tasks that we need to
do we now got to put them into priority
orders so as I say week three but
um work is ongoing and go on going fast
all right um councilman McLaren
um I
Services
Association was absolutely first class
it was very perceptive and very balanced
and they'd obviously listen to people
but when I went through all the detail
I couldn't find any reference
to the senior leadership and management
oversight of the Electoral services
manager and his staff and I would like
to ask who was actually undertaking that
thank you do you mean now what do you
mean back in May I mean back during the
yes not not now yes Yes actually
thinking about the answers the same but
I just thought I'd be clear
um so in terms of line management
structures the elections manager reports
into the director of Law and governance
so if the alley who then reports in
currently reports into me there are
maybe some other changes that we're
going to make around the senior
leadership team in the coming months but
the expectation is that that post will
report into director of law
which is another post that we're out to
advert for at the moment because as
councils will be aware
um Mr Ali is a interim member of staff
and leaves us at the end of October
which in and of itself creates a little
bit of a risk around delivery of
Elections because
similarly if we think backwards and
without getting into personal details
councilors some counselors will be aware
of Mr Ali's personal circumstances which
were difficult at the turn of the year
played and
over the previous manager
I just ask another question yes
certainly thank you
do you think there are any lessons for
senior management team to learn from
this exercise thank you there are in
network there are loads there's three
pages worth I would say
um and plus some I think the main one
for me is making sure that as we recruit
to Jules permanent post and equally with
Jill in terms of her role that there is
less line management which may sound
like a strange thing to say but a direct
Loop into me that's what I'm familiar
with that's what I'm used to in terms of
the elections managers approach with the
returning officer um clearly there's
nothing
today and clearly there's a role for
line Management in terms of as a
described Passions
don't don't feel as though they can't
come and talk directly to me where there
are issues I haven't changed my Approach
but certainly I can immediately see how
that has changed depending on the person
who's been in post
thank you thank you chair yeah Council
and register
okay it's working
um
number of
elect for Parish elections were
initially declared as uncontested and
then subsequently we discovered they
weren't but quite late in the day
um maybe a week and afternoon after the
apparent close of nominations
um and people were worried that that
might happen again and the other
question was when we got the costs at
Subway Town Council for the elections
people wanted to know how the costs for
an uncontested election are calculate
and they varied quite
you know you know one member wards
and there were different prices
different costs um that's all
so happy to take both those away because
I suspect looking to my left there's not
something that my colleagues were able
to answer here and now unless you feel
feel again if you
want you to write into us or contact
s or tell me which of the um parishes
you're thinking of then we can I can but
also just to say that it is based on the
number of electorates so they will they
they will vary
and in terms of the statements of
persons nominated clearly that was the
main issue that we had during the
election
um any other issues to a large extent
stemmed from there so fell from there if
you like
um and certainly the original statement
a person is nominated that was published
if it was a Tuesday or Wednesday I'm
trying to remember now which no other
week Wednesday I think it was
um was incorrect we knew that and
therefore making corrections to that but
that did take some time to make sure
that we apps
I don't say that as any form of excuse
but to put that in the context of we
have over 1200 nominations and what we
started to do immediately was make sure
every single one of them was correct in
every shape or form uh
solely focus
Ed so that did take some time
thank you yeah I've got Council of Rhys
next please
sorry if this has been covered elsewhere
but um given that project planning is of
the utmost Elementary nature of any kind
of project and it's not the first time
anybody's faced elections
I'm just wondering why you know we've
got um
a call for a um a comprehensive and
robust elections team plan with key
Milestones Etc
yes unfortunate personal circumstances
earlier in the year notwithstanding why
wasn't there already
a robust plan in place
is the right question absolutely so uh
just to not so much correct so for some
within the team this was their first
election so in that respect some within
the team are going through through the
process for the first time but certainly
from a management perspective it wasn't
the first election that they'd run the
first election they run here and
certainly as I say there is an element
to which we're not special we're not
that different but we are large
geographically and Rural and have a
large number of parishes that we support
and therefore that does bring slight
difference if you're used to running an
election in Ipswich for example it's a
very different experience very different
experience but there was whilst there
was a project plan and project meetings
at a higher level should we say um the
high chair that wasn't and hence the
recommendation a
service itself and clearly that's an
obvious thing that needs to be put in
place particularly where you've got uh
or had at the time in experienced
elections team so even more that they
had that that there is a backup
the second question I had was that um
the change in system of dealing with
registers registration of interests for
counselors
there were changes that occurred at the
same time as these elections
um why was that the case was that to do
with the recent legislation you know why
did all that happen at the same time as
as the elections
so um we changed the system of
registration of interest for parishes
and councils because it was the district
and Parish elections and it made sense
that you you know you've got to fill in
a new register to do it at that point
and so that was the the rationale behind
that but um all parishes should have
been notified and given contact details
and we have actually worked through that
whole process with support from the team
and I'm really pleased to say that
actually we've got the highest return
rate that we've ever had on the new
system for register of interest for
parishes and districts I think we're up
to about 94 which is always a role you
know there's always an element where
councils are actually um retiring or
have resigned or for whatever reason so
um before we were sitting about 81 so
that's that's a really good positive
result but yes the reason why we've done
it was because it was all our elections
and it was a sensible time to to to
replace everything at one go
Al or did it actually help so the actual
registration of Interest was run by the
governance team and there was an office
two officers assigned to that so
um this was aside from the elections
team so it didn't cause any problems
right okay thanks very much and sorry
Jeff I have a third final question if I
may please very well
um and um
I would just like to ask
um what purple
training
teams
um for the elections was carried out
um online as opposed to in person and
um was there any assessment as to
whether that was problematic or not
please
please so the majority of the online
training was for presiding officers and
old clerks in the bowling stations
themselves I believe him right saying
that was 100 online
um that's possibly the first time we've
done it that way I'm just trying to
remember that things possibly the first
time we've done it that way obviously
the significant change that we had for
these elections compared to previous
ones was the introduction of voter ID
and therefore needed to make sure that
that Paul Clarkson presiding officers
were confident with that process but
also we had
as well so not just confident with that
new element but confident with the whole
process itself we are exploring whether
or not for uh future elections whether
there is some software that we could use
within the polling stations for uh Paul
clerks and presiding officers to make it
a lot simpler the risk factor around
that which is why we're looking
carefully at it is that and ironically
as demonstrated this morning in this
building you're Reliant upon signal and
you can well you will be familiar with
where some of our polling stations are
and the fact that you can't get 1G let
alone two or three so that may not be an
option but certainly what we've planned
within this action plan is to provide
anon on an online offer in terms of
training but also an additional
face-to-face offer as well because
certainly for new staff are the feedback
that we had was that it would have been
nice and would have given them a greater
sense of assurance if they had had an
opportunity once they collected their
ballot boxes so once they had all of
their paperwork in front of them and
have a chance to digest it and having on
the online offer just to make sure that
they were comfortable with what they
were doing particularly
below to ID having said that and I'm
hopeful nobody's now going to throw an
example back back in my face and say
there was a problem but the experience
for innovator in the polling station was
good
to work but we think it would be better
about Embraces to provide both
yes um just just to remind you that the
um there will be a debate and so you can
express any opinions
um in in the debate but I have um
another question from councilor Patchett
no thank you chair I've I've got kind of
two points now hopefully I'll try and
sort of merge them into one um so I
think my ward particularly sort of ball
the brunt of the of the mistakes are
made because
um it was my ward that had the incorrect
ballot papers
um that had to be sort of sent out and I
think my address I think on town I I had
my address on on and then on District I
don't think it did that's that's a minor
thing
um but you know the ballot paper was was
definitely a big thing and I think my
again I was one of the ones where my
nomination wasn't initially sort of on
on the website
um one of the one of the issues and I
don't even think this is covered
actually in our review is that I went to
all of my polling stations and sort of
spoke to people after they had voted to
sort of redirect that
um and sort of canvas them and some
people sort of went as a family group so
you sort of had like mum mum dad son
um and we had households that had newly
moved into my ward where say Dad was
registered but mum and Son were not and
even though they had put all the
paperwork through for all of them at the
same time and perhaps I haven't seen it
but I don't think situations like that
have we have we did we dip into that
um in the review where sort of family
groups yeah like some people were off
the register and like why were they off
the register so that's kind of like part
part one
so no we didn't dip into that as part of
this review uh not least because we
haven't had a lot of reporting of that
back to us I'll look to my colleagues in
a minute who work I think we'll be able
to give an explanation of that um the
one thing I was going to say and you're
absolutely right so thorny uh bore the
brunt of some of the issues not meant as
an excuse but just as a very practical
thing
um it Bears the same name both at the
parish and at the CA and at the district
Ward level so you ballot paper whereas
normally you'd easily be able to spot
well what's this about paper for it's
for stay thorny okay which Stow thorny
that's not a situation that we're
experience in any other Parish or Ward
level they have different names now to
be fair to places strangely enough that
that's right so you would expect to do
the same name but there's a there's just
very simple things which means why we've
had to build in and make sure we've got
additional checks because where we have
staff who are not familiar with our area
and Jill wasn't here at the time but she
won't mind me mentioning the fact that
both her accent and where she lives is
not in in Suffolk
if you don't know that actually it
appears twice then it's very easy to
make a very simple mistake and making
sure that we've got those kind of things
covered off for the future
snow thorny was uncommon in being
district and and that's why in the the
ballot papers that we had to reissue and
it's not it will feel unusual if you're
in snow thoroughly but it's not unusual
to have to reissue some ballot papers to
make a minor correction I think it's
about 600 ballot papers that we had to
had to reissue that in another
a significant issue you'd rather not
have to do it for obvious reasons
um but yes that transcribing from one
ballot paper to the other so that where
it said I forget which way around it was
I think it's a vote for no more than two
where it should have said vote for no
matter four because it was correct that
language on the other ballot paper but
wrong for that ballot paper but they
both stay thorny so that's how you how
we get into some of those how we have
particularly in that area with that
issue I mean because I I know I 100 lost
lost votes on that and so did sort of
Colin lay who who I sit with because we
were chatting to people and they said oh
yeah we did vote for you on the postal
vote but we're now moving house and we
probably won't be here when the next
paper comes through and I think there
was another guy who was like a truck
driver
um and he said yeah he said I've already
voted for you but that papers obviously
now void and when the next one comes in
I'll probably be away truck driving so I
know we did lose those but then again so
did probably some of the other
candidates as well probably all sort of
leveled out
um but I didn't I only spoke to people
that said oh yes we would have voted for
you they didn't actually say oh no we
weren't for the other guy so I know that
we definitely lost votes it wouldn't
surprise me people don't tend to say
that
but I looked to jail in just in terms of
that explanation about registration yeah
yes I was just going to pick up on your
registration Point
um where part of a family isn't
registered although they all registered
together maybe online or put a paper
form in and I mean what happens is that
your name is your name and your details
go off to DWP to be verified and not
everybody comes back as we call the
green elector some some of them come
back Amber or red we had lots of those
in midst of a green electors and then
and then those those ones that are
marked up as not um as as not verifying
we then have to send out further um
communication and inquiry forms and ask
for further Evidence either a copy of
your passport or your driving license or
other documents so it may be that where
men and you also have a deadline and
before the sixth day and before the day
of poll to actually make sure that you
you um your documents come back to us
and and you can be verified to be able
to vote so it may be that if if one of a
member of the families didn't didn't
actually send their forms back in time
or their documents back in time that
might have been why
um you know two or two or three of them
weren't registered or were registered
and one wasn't and but they do although
they're registered before
um the 11th day and before Powell
they've the 12th day sorry before poll
will then they've got until the sixth
day before Pearl to actually get there
and their forms in yeah no thanks for
the answers from both of you because you
you have Yeah you sort of answered and
put my mind a bit at ease
um
it would be nicer I think if we could
yeah okay so questions so part two then
I'll forget we'll forget part one thanks
for your answers
um part two now we've all I think as a
as a council I think we almost dodged a
bullet on on this last election because
so we were previously the conservative
Administration then we've moved to Green
we we could have almost have had uh you
know an America 2020 situation with with
a contested election if if the
conservatives had have stayed in because
what you would have had was a kind of a
council that was conservative run and
then if the cat if the conservatives had
won it and and say the greens hadn't
um
we we would have probably have mounted
like a legal challenge because of all of
the failings in the system heading for a
question here there is a question yeah
there is a question so what my question
to you is I have to lay some context
um would be how how would you have dealt
if it had been closer if if people had
you know if the conservatives and
agreeing said maybe it was only like a
you know a dozen votes in it how would
you have actually have dealt with that
because you would have had
two people in a ward who would have said
well I think I am actually the the legal
winner of this Ward and how would you
have dealt with these legal challenges
um and who actually would have you have
allowed to have occupied the scene
because we could have been in a position
where actually we we didn't form a
council because there were legal
challenges going on how would you have
dealt with that would you have
outsourced it then would you well I
guess would you have outsourced the
election a re-election to another sort
of County to run because of the failings
in this County how do you have sort of
dealt with with a much closer election
thank you and the Preamble was helpful
um so no answer to the latter bit and
fortunately I don't have to determine
what happens when there's a legal
process because there's a legal process
kicks in so election petitions can be
mounted where anyone believes that the
result of the election was incorrect uh
inaccurate should we say for whatever
reason uh you're absolutely right we
didn't receive an election petition
election petition is a rare touchwood I
don't ever wish to receive one but if we
did then we would be into that process
they then are judge-led in terms of
determining what was the outcome what
was the right outcome I've been
confident throughout regardless of how
tight or otherwise it was and obviously
that puts additional focus on it but
I've been confident confident and
comfortable throughout that the results
of all of the elections that were
declared were correct and that's my sole
Focus I don't really care politely which
one of you wins in fact I'm not allowed
to care which one of you wins nor
whether it's closer and certainly we're
familiar with that so not this last
elections but the one before two Awards
One in Baba one in mid-suffolk were tied
uh that was determined by drawing Lots
um so I'm more than comfortable and
familiar with the fact that we we can
get some very close results but the
ultimate determination on how the
council is administered is a separate
process clearly made up of the numbers
of the votes
um and yes as I said already I was
comfortable that the mitigations that we
put in place and there weren't
mitigations because things went wrong
but the mitigations that we put in place
made sure that the result was the
correct result of I.E the one that the
voters voted for but if somebody had
brought an election petition then we
would have dealt with that accordingly
thank you are there any further
questions and we uh Council Awards
thank you chairman if ever may this
question concerning the EMS we touched
on on training and making sure that's
adequate enough but um obviously one of
the problems was there's a specific bug
in the system which only transpired in
in the last election
um are we confident that we've
identified all future possible bugs
particularly we've got different
elections coming up
excuse me general election PCC have we
tested against all potential use cases
for those different elections
and furthermore are there any changes
that we would like to see in the EMS to
make those elections easier to
administer and and has has that work
been is that work being undertaken with
the supplier and again making sure that
the testing is is thorough and complete
I'll start and then again Jan and Joe
wanted to add
um so we are fortunate or misfortunate
I'm not sure which in this country that
there are about three uh providers of
election software across the whole
country and so there is not exactly a
vast Choice when it comes to running
elections and inevitably over the years
we have become more and more Reliant
upon that software for every single part
of the election it doesn't mean we
couldn't revert to paper and pencils a
bit like in the polling station if we
had to
um but we have become more and more
Reliant upon it the bug you're
absolutely right we did discover a bug
that was not unique to us it applied
across all the software across the
country and they've subsequently issued
a patch to fix it
um I would say that the reason we
discovered that is because we had a
difference problem so in trying to fix a
previous problem not a software related
problem we discovered the bug that was
the one that led to a number of
candidates being described as local
conservative on the uh on the statement
a person is nominated when they weren't
that was automatically filled by the
system not by us which as you can
imagine when you're not even in that
field comes as a bit of a surprise so
that bit has been fixed
um I'm confident in the software Supply
I'm also more confident in the fact that
they have uh clearly recognized that
they have a relationship with us that
they want to sustain and it's not good
for their reputation either when a
council has issues regardless of the
level of software issue or not and so
they've been all over us politely to
make sure that we stay with them for the
future if and at the moment we have no
intention of changing necessarily but
clearly all contracts reach a point and
we go through a procurement exercise and
then the more fundamental one for me is
making sure that our staff are
familiar with the software and
understand how it works because having
said there's only a few providers
they're slightly different in terms of
how they're how they present obviously
it's the same election that ultimately
has to be delivered but they're doing
ever so slightly different ways and so
we've already had additional training
for our staff on the software and that
will carry on and similarly the software
provider is offered to Second some of
their staff into our team for a period
of time if we would like which we are
taking them up on that offer
if I can just come back a
and we've
counts with their I.T guys and Rit guys
and and some of our staff to to go
through the issues we're planning
um very shortly to set up the test
um elections so that they can thoroughly
test that out with ourselves ahead and
we're hoping to do that in the next
couple of weeks
um so
um as I say and our staff have
undertaken lots more training with them
and we've got lots more planned
and and I should add
um whilst doesn't capture the same level
of attention obviously we have run
elections since a regularly running
elections during the year because we
have by-elections at Parish level and
also neighborhood plan referendums so we
will continue to use the software for
those purposes as well
sorry just the other part of the
question
um about any future changes to the
system uh that we might require are we
going to request any or who's that so we
have a wish list and that goes forward
with our fortnightly meetings so we have
we're putting down what we see as as
changes that we'd like them to make and
um they they review those and come back
to us and tell tell us where they are
with it what is possible and what is not
so yeah we we're constantly looking at
what we can do and also we're also
looking at the speed of the delivery as
well of the system which has also been a
problem in the past so that is also
being investigated
um
like all of their clients we're part of
the user group so it's not just us
putting in our wish list it's all of the
users for all the other clients
all right
um I have a couple more Council register
has another question who
um actually it follows on from what you
were just talking about so if there's an
update to the software either a bug fix
or a feature Edition because you've
requested something our EMS running
um both functional and behavioral driven
tests to ensure that there are no
regressions in the software so by adding
this feature you actually bring
something else which is now becoming
quite common in software development and
ensures that every time you add a fit
you bug you don't break something else
because everything works as it did
before except those bits that have been
fixed by the bug or feature Edition
and um have you raised have you as
and if you don't if you if you don't
quite comprehend what I mean I'm happy
to elucidate but uh
would that be something you would take
up with the supplies
um I'm just going to say that when
um any of the EMS providers before they
actually send us the um the data to to
upload it is robustly tested and I can
understand exactly what you're saying
and but they they have to assure us that
it is because it is put straight into a
live system then because all all of the
changes are to do with legislation and
so that we do get their guarantee that
they that they do robustly and test it
before we get it and there is a large
update coming in October because of the
changes in in absent voting and
um and we all know that this will have
been tested but yes I can I can
understand exactly what you're saying
and we just we just have to keep testing
the system and we um as well as the um
the meetings that Jan's mentioned they
also have meetings with me and every
Friday day now and every Friday morning
to go through it and also
um the EMS providers have been providing
even extra
um training and I've got another one
this afternoon to to get take me through
the system and because there's
um Arthur said they all do the same they
all do the same the main three and but
they're all slightly different
um in their way of thinking and I'm I'm
I have been another provider she um use
that have used all that myself
um Express but democracy counts is a new
one to me but they have been very good
in providing extra training for us all
and as well as me they are giving extra
training to the staff
yeah to give them confidence councilman
McLaren
it's a
it's a big question for a lot of Voters
was voter ID
many people made lots of comments
how big a problem was that during these
last elections and what
should we be doing to prepare for the
next election thank you thank you
so I think I'd probably say
um we have ended up focusing on the what
went wrong uh and rightly so what we've
not focused on particularly is what went
right and I would say voter ID was in
that category because
um we planned for the worst and didn't
experience it
um so very few problems in the polling
stations some anomalies if you like
identification that you would have
assumed would be allowable but isn't on
the list of allowable
identification and therefore needed to
be turned away so things like police
warrant cards and it's an interesting
exercise when you have a member of Staff
having said a police officer no sorry
you can't vote
to come back with a different set of
identification but government have taken
away some of those lessons and the
meeting we had as I say last week with
the Electoral commission they are
revisiting the list of approved
identification that's good that's
positive what that also means for future
poll clubs and presiding officers is yet
an even longer list of things you need
to check through to see whether or not
it's a valid ID but it would appear
based on the numbers that we had a
relatively positive experience over
other voters had a relatively positive
experience in terms of voter ID but I'm
very conscious that we had a district
and Parish level turnout and
election level turnout and so there will
be voters I'm sure who only vote a
parliamentary who have managed to miss
the fact that the law has changed so
um yes I'll take this opportunity again
as a public meeting to reiterate it
every election you need to bring along
one of the valid forms of identification
if you don't have a valid form of
identification we can provide you with
it but you need to apply sufficiently in
advance to allow us time to be able to
process the application to be able to
provide it with you and provide it to
you or you can have a postal vote
instead and where you don't have to
worry at all about voter ID but clearly
that's a choice for the voters but no it
would appear in all of our polling
stations that the message had been heard
and that people did either come along
with ID or went back and got it and came
back again very few people were turned
away and we didn't use which was one of
the suggestions from the Electoral
commission we didn't use greeters
lastly because we would have struggled
to be able to employ yet another 180
staff to stand that the of a polling
station to ask somebody as they walked
in rather than ask them when they walk
in
um so we don't think we had many
actually
what I mean
come back
sorry I think
can I just have a quick word first I was
just going to say that I'm
reading um about voting that there was a
suggestion by some DM that somebody who
already whose idea had already been
accepted might be allowed to vouch for
somebody else is that a no-go
absolutely not no
um and this is one of the difficulties
in terms of Staff as well because you
can imagine particularly where we tend
to have Paul Clark on a presiding
officer from that Village They Know Who
You Are
but they still need to see the
identification and that's quite helpful
as returning officers quite helpful
because that means everything is very
black and white we don't get into this
situation of vouching I think one of the
issues has raised me more recently not
at the time around
for their wife well no I don't know it's
your wife and even if I do know it's
your wife you still need to produce the
identification and it's not my rules
we're just there to administer it but no
definitely not absolutely
and the councilman have a little bit
more there on the end
thank you chair
given that we need to be starting early
for the network whichever the next
election is is it possible to
encourage Ward members and Parish
councils to start some sort of
message very early on and continue with
that message
thank you
I mean we can do I can take that forward
and one one of the things that we are
going to do which is part of a meeting
with the media team is that we will
start the campaign again and the
Electoral commission definitely will
start the campaign again for voter ID
and actually last Friday I'd went to
visit storage the depot and where all
the election equipment is kept and in
there are all the banners all rolled up
that we used about voter ID so we said
oh great they're all in good condition
we'll use them again so we're going to
get those out that was one of the things
we'll use that again to when to put out
where they were last time but uh there
will be in our campaign again for voter
ID so it won't be that it'll just been
forgotten and it'll all be about absent
voting this year
put that back as well and as Arthur did
say the Electoral commission and D look
are looking to expand the list of um of
acceptable forms of ID to bring
thank you thank you
thank you are there any further
questions we've seen each other the good
um really again another one very really
short one
a really short one
um if you if they were doing something
publicly like they can't climate chain
work claims change Workshops can we not
have a banner saying have you got your
voter ID just to remind people
we absolutely can I think the challenge
always is which of the particular
messages we want to encourage people to
focus on at any given event but the
principle absolutely yeah
thank you well if there are no more
questions
um
I just like little guidance from the
um monitoring officer
um
my my
um my detailed running order doesn't
suggest that there should be a debate
but I think people should have the
opportunity to express any opinions that
don't fit within the general description
of questions
um before we move to a vote is that all
right
yesterday it's a normal committee so
it's questions and debate
any any um anybody like to say anything
before we move to a vote
of we I think all the um all the let's
say all the concerns
um that people have I think are very
largely emerged from the questioning and
um I think thanks to the returning
officer very detailed
uh says and um so I have councilman
Whitehead
thank you I think most other
observations rather than questions that
I sort of bad in my time
being a counselor here I think I've been
through four elections district council
elections and it felt more different
recently because going back to the early
years like 2011 the Electoral team I
think there was an electoral manager and
various assistants between them sort of
had 20 years experience each and sort of
knew the mid-suffic
um Awards and parishes like the back of
their hands and unfortunately you know
you lose that experience and you know
you can't replicate it so I think this
used with Stowe Thornley that that's
sort of thing that someone who sort of
personally knew the area really well
would have got on that straight away so
if you can't sort of replicate
experience straight away I do wonder
whether we ought to be careful not to
understand this area I'm guessing back
again in 2011 there was two lots of
Staffing there was a behavior electoral
team in the mid Suffolk team and it's
fine to be able to say now we pay for
half chief executive one of a section
151 officer but I think on the election
side
um because it isn't an administrative
exercise an academic exercise it's
crucial that um we don't try and cook
Corners there and and if anything we
need more staff than we have because you
can't replace 20 or 30 years of
experience and again I've worked through
two um
Community governance reviews and and the
contrast between those two were really
quite Stark the first one the Electoral
team you know they put the Wellies on
and actually gone and looked round the
area you know walked the ward when
they're looking at boundaries and things
like that and then again they were
leading members on that a second time
around it just felt it had been done as
a sort of Google Earth exercise and
they're pretty clueless as to say where
the winners and Stone Market boundaries
lay and you know all sorts of issues
arose from that so
um I think what I'm trying to say is
let's not cook corners and make sure
adequately start
thank you I think sometimes when you do
make a mistake which we have a good
review turns over all the stones and we
learn from that so as far as I can
proceed from the whole process very
positive great to see the thoroughness
in which it's been undertaken and I
think it's been a really worthwhile
exercise
it's just this is just almost a
suggestion really and on page 46 under
resource it's referring to the um
accessibility and um any additional
resources that may be required and who
might carry that out those things and
those reviews if you like
um I was just wondering whether there'd
be scope for our locality officers to
help with that at all as and when they
visit
Awards especially out in the Villages
where most of the most of the polling
stations take place in the um in the
village halls and
other buildings where elections which
are used as polling sessions
just a comment thanks
yes please though we are going to be
undertaking a polling District review
and it's planned for later in the year
one of the first things we're going to
do is survey all the um previous
presiding offices but and and polling
inspectors but also go out to town and
Parish liaison groups to talk to the
clerks because actually they know who's
in their Village and the ward councilors
and the parish councils so as part of
that consultation everybody will be
involved in giving some feedback and the
plan is to to go around to those polling
stations that we're not so familiar with
to have a look and make ourselves
familiar with all of that so a lot of
work to be done but that is in the plan
going forward for that polling District
review
anybody else yes councilor McLaren
prompt when the problem occurred and
contacting the Electoral commission and
obviously we had the review I I think
that was very commendable and we've had
a very I think a very positive outcome
to them thank you
councilman Patrick
try not to turn this into the Patrick
Show but anyway
um
again I'm just I'm just looking at this
sort of chart at the moment and there's
quite a lot of a quite a lot of red on
there
um
do and also I'd actually I'd like to
agree with sort of councilors Wyman
um and Whitehead that yes I so yeah I
think it is good that we do a review so
yeah I'd like to second that as well and
also councilor Whitehead yeah perhaps we
do need a local knowledge and we need a
mid-suffolk electors team and we need a
baby electors team clap this is one
place where we do need to to divide
um so again I'm just looking at the you
know the the not started
um what did did I don't know if anyone
else asked but did we actually put a
time frame on that because we've got an
up-and-coming sort of general election
um
but not started and the Reds and the and
the ambers what is this is there a time
frame to turn them Greener Amber
so as a previously said this is the
first two weeks the the next task for us
is to go through and actually put dates
in as to when we need to get those
started by when we need to to to to meet
the Milestones within that so you know
there is an elections project plan which
will come behind that but the plan is to
to start them all as soon as we
practically can but
baptization at the moment we have to get
the annual canvas out of the way poly
District review started and get the
legislation and the new boundary changes
into the system so that we're up and
running so that's our main focus at the
moment but the work is you know free
Assurance work is going on about
elections as alluded to we're already
planning on looking at new venues for
the next election looking at the
logistics behind that what we need to do
working out how many ballot boxes we do
so that's all in we've booked the
polling stations there's only three that
we've got a query with for across both
districts so we are ahead and it is
being done it's just a matter of putting
the metrics into into that
it is all going on
God just Rook can I replied it's just I
know like with myself personally I am
sort of if I've got I've got a whole
list of jobs
um
just because of the way my brain works I
never do anything until there's a
deadline and like the last minute and
um yeah I'll admit that I'm guilty of
that so
um the the pro I am turning this into
the patchy show as well
um I guess the problem is if we don't
put like a timeline on it you know
perhaps people just go yeah okay you
know the people that are responsible for
it might actually just go hey I'll do
this this next big sort of crocodile and
I won't do with this even if we just put
arbitrary on it of just say like 31st of
March just put something on it because
how can you how can you measure
performance with no actual end goal you
know there's certain criteria you hit
you need to hit because you put red
Amber Greens on it that's a measure of
performance if you don't actually put a
deadline on it I want this done by
um
you know we we are we can't measure that
performance so I think the very next
thing we need to do I think you probably
said that we're going to do it we we've
got to put done by on it because I know
our people work and people if there's no
date people won't do it they'll do
they'll just brush it off
probably more than that but there's
three elements that I think are
fundamentally missing from this and that
I'm looking for in the next iteration
um one is the accountable officer for
each of the tasks one is the deadline
for each of the tasks and then the third
is the interdependencies
um which I suppose in effect is the
prioritization to some degree but it's
how these different actions relate to
each other because clearly some do some
don't and I think that would be helpful
because I
I made the points I suppose that some of
these actually relate only to our next
district and Parish elections which we
know are not for four years
you can't see that from this document
help then the project team in particular
but also the project board in terms of
assessing this by exception to be able
to say okay that one's doesn't need to
be done yet doesn't mean it doesn't need
to ever be done and certainly doesn't
need to be left to the last possible
minute but at least then you can see the
flow so I'm expecting some kind of
advanced chart to be honest um it's
going to be the next iteration but what
we wanted to get you is the the first
iteration and hear your thoughts are
these very deliberately a draft that
will continue
and um I'm fairly sure there'll be
further government legislation in the
next four years that will add yet more
to the elections
if I can just in terms of while I've got
the floor and answer to councilor
Whitehead's question
um I don't know what the elections teams
look like in terms of the numbers back
in 2011 until it's 12 but I'm fairly
sure you're right and that there would
have been probably a team that's nearly
double what we've got now possibly not
quite double and certainly would have
had
experience in it
in terms of Elections knowledge which is
clearly important but also in terms of
patch knowledge which is also important
and certainly elections knowledge is the
is the thing that we had an absence of
as we went through the last elections
um
Australian training plans in place in
order to build up but I'm particularly
grateful that you raised it while the
section 151 officer sat to my right
because they think you're right to the
team needs to grow and therefore there
will cost implication
implications thank you any anybody else
um I've if not I've just a few um
observations really
um clearly these these elections weren't
the uh you know our finest hour so to
speak but
um I think it was it was reassuring
soon after the election to to hear a
clear statement that the the election
and the outcome of the election had been
um
was satisfactory and safe I think was it
was the term that was used and
um the I think the the the elect the
plan we've got in front of us at the
moment uh is uh it's a checklist of all
the recommendations and that's that's a
good start that the officers or all of
the officers that have assured me
earlier on this morning that the the
structure
um and
interconnection and indeed the deadlines
and so on that that work is is
going on and there will be another
another plan which possibly will need to
look at again
um briefly briefly next time
um to see that it's all going forward
comfortably and well and um so if
nobody's got anything else that they
want you to say then I will ask for the
vote to be held on
noting this um
the report and the plan
yeah yeah well we do need a proposal in
a second for this apparently right we
have councilor
um Dowling and um Patrick and others
thank you chair that is now in progress
on my gov
thank you chair there's no votes for
that's unanimous
thank you that's that's unanimous then
um I I don't think it would be a good
plan to have a break halfway through the
the other main item so I suggest that we
take a five minute or so break now uh
what we've got 52
minutes of that should we
right are we no right the
other main item of our business
we'll be discussing a report which is
entirely confidential so I propose that
we
move straight to that process
and so I'm proposing that we exclude the
public
and the proposal is to consider whether
pursuing to part one
of schedule 12a of the Local Government
Act 1972 the public should be excluded
from the meeting for the business
specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this item it is likely
that there would be the disclosure to
them of exempt information as indicated
against the item the author of the
report proposed to be considered in
parts of the agenda is satisfied that
the public interest in maintaining the
exemption outweighs the public interest
in disclosing the information can either
proposal to go into closed session let's
cancel the register with Council McLaren
thank you right show of hands those in
favor
thank you
live thank you
right
are we coming up for an electronic vote
just just a moment
can we hear the um can we hear what
we're now going to vote on
okay do you want me to assist with that
but to to note the recommendations in
the report and that um a future report
before
joint order and standards committee yeah
I think that's what um
working on
just asking just to read it back
did you have a time scale which I don't
think any any views two months four
months
right I I I was the second two months
next meeting in other words
right you always to read that now
yeah so to note the contents of the
report and confidential appendix a and
that a future report will be brought
back to the Joint order and standards
committee within two months
all right
thank you chair that boat is now in
progress on vodka
councilor Reece can I take your vote
verbally
can I take you back perfectly
um
councilor Marriott can I take your vote
please
can I take your break verbally then
thank you chair but it's my advice for
that unanimous
we have the forward plan
and we're obviously adding on to that
what we've just asked for
any other
comments on the forward plan
right
no problems we need a vote on that
no vote on that good right
thank you very much everybody and um I
look forward to seeing you at the next
meeting on the 27th of November
includes the meeting